all right scarlett yes
scarlett oh where'd you grow up where
are you from originally san antonio
texas san antonio uh-huh i'm the
youngest of five
um
[Music]
it was a nice place to grow up i guess
it was
just like any other place i guess but i
had kind of a rougher
childhood than most people
in what ways
my mom was an alcoholic my father was an
alcoholic my step-dad was abusive and
um
i grew up way too soon
my mom
was a she molested me at the age of five
but my mom had multiple personality
disorder so she didn't know she did it
and um i never told
so
so you were born male 1 male 1 but
you're trans now uh-huh when did you
my whole life i always felt like i was
different than everybody else i knew
there was something
i like to say special more special about
me than them but
at like 12 20 13 i told my parents my
mom saw me i was crying and she said she
would rather have a gay slum than a dead
one and i told her that
i felt like it was a woman inside and
started the process
do you think the sexual abuse in your
childhood kind of directed you that way
no
no something you're born with i yeah
i've always felt like i was different
and
it's not it had nothing to do with that
now it turned me hypersexual
like the sexual abuse when i was younger
i
got into prostitution and started having
sex
at like 10
so yeah
10 years old 10 years old wow
you finished school
i got my ged
in prison
what were you in prison for
um
prostitution
in texas any three of the same
misdemeanors becomes an automatic felony
and that was
a prostitution you were dressed as a
male or a female i was a female i've
lived my life as a female since i was
13. since 13. okay
and how old are you now i am 42. 42.
so you moved to l.a at what at what
point
10 years ago
um my husband and my mom
passed away three hours apart
wow
so i moved down here
tell me how la is different than texas
for a trans woman
la's more accepting
they don't care you can walk down the
street in a die high boots and a little
mini skirt and nobody's that's an
eyelash in texas they're gonna throw
rocks at you
but
it's texas is more you know
conservative it's on how you carry
yourself
people when i got here i was shocked at
it was a culture shock for me because in
texas people are so polite you know they
say good morning you passed by to open
the door for you things like that here
it's just like it seems like everybody's
out for themselves but in a way i needed
that because i was so busy thinking
about everybody else over there that i
did nothing for myself until i got here
and drugs are part of your life right
now yes
they've been part of my life since i was
13.
at first it was just to get away from
everything to stop um
then when my husband passed away i am
[Music]
i couldn't take the pain
so
i did as much as i could
anything i could i could have heroin
coke
crystal
i did it all in one day
trying to kill myself i guess
didn't find no reason to live
stupid i'm still addicted to him
but
it's i can control it a lot more now
than i could before because before i
couldn't control it i was
as much as i could do and
as little time possible
and now i just
it's not the main thing i think about
when i wake up anymore
the death of your husband kind of set
you on that bat he stopped me on heroin
yeah
oh he started he started me when he died
it started me on heroin
because he um he did heroin before
and i was just smoking crack and stuff
in texas and
when he died it was like
like no pain i'd ever felt before in my
life
that you never want to feel
again he was the love of your life
no
he was just one of them
i was blessed with somebody else
who he oh he used to tell me
girl because he used to call me red i'm
just i'm a natural redhead he said tell
me red you're gonna find that guy out
there that's gonna put up your [ __ ]
and
you know he's you're gonna give it right
back to him and
he was talking about tony
and
it just it happened so abruptly
he was hit by a car
tustin 75 feet in the air broke every
bone in his body
and then my mom died three hours after
that
she lost her fight to cancer and
it was like
completely dark in my life
i didn't think about
it my whole life my whole childhood
everything that i went through
i always kept like this
but in the back of my head because my
mom always said if you're faithful to
god if you're true to god if you believe
in his word he's gonna
come through
but
when everything happened to me when i
was a kid where was he then i asked when
they passed away i asked myself what was
god then when
when i was getting raped when i was
getting beaten when uh where was he then
and then i lost my family my mom and my
husband and
it was like the most it shook my face
shook my faith in god
i found it again
but
it's just it's hard every day is hard
how do you support yourself now i'm
prostituting still
yeah
i am
was 14 you know i was 16
and living in san antonio
and my mom i was working at kfc
and i would come down i was living in
braunfels texas and we'd come down every
weekend because i always had the
weekends off
and one weekend i had to work and i sent
my mom down she got arrested
and i moved back down to san antonio
and i gave my dad this money to get me
an apartment because my um
my godfather owns a set of apartments
and my dad gave me the money i gave him
the money i'm sorry and he's put me in
motown for the night said
i'll come back for you in the morning
the next morning the landlord's banging
on the door tells me i gotta go i threw
all my clothes away uh the place to
prostitute in san antonio's broadway i
step foot on broadway and i pop my first
leg
i've been doing it ever since
it's like i got addicted to the money
not the lifestyle
i was poor growing up
i suffered and i wanted i went to bed
hungry
and since i started prostituting i never
ever have to do that again so
tell me about the guys who pick you up
they're different
some of them are real
um
most of them are bottoms
my ad says i'm a ts top so
that's what i do so for those that don't
know what that means that that means
you're i am fully functional and i still
use my penis
doesn't mean you're more you're more
dominant as well yes yeah
to some to some
depending on what they want
or how they act within like first five
minutes of conversation with one of them
i already know what they want but
they're getting a different person
they're not getting the real me they're
not no they never get to see the real me
they couldn't handle it
so what they get is a version of what
they want
their conversation tells me what they
want i become that person when you say
they couldn't handle the real you
what qualities do you have that
would make it difficult for people to
handle
i'm not as much of a [ __ ] as people
think
i'm not sensitive
excuse me
i'm real sensitive
and i wasn't raised to be that way
um
in my family you had to be tough thank
you
you had to be tough you had to
my mom was like
she was like mean my mom would
the first time i ever got my my got beat
up when i was younger my mom backed me
into a corner she put on boxing gloves
and she boxed me until i fought back
people
a lot of my friends think i'm the
strongest person in the world and i'm
not
i'm not
i don't have all the answers for
everybody else i can fix everybody
else's problems but my own
i cause more harm to myself than i do to
anybody else
and um
why i don't know
i don't know what to do anymore what
emotions do you struggle with most
um
forgiveness
that's the hardest thing for me to do
because i see the people that victimize
me and they're living great lives
then it pisses me off because how could
they know
they took something from me
and now they're living in nice houses
with their families
they took away my childhood my innocence
and just threw me aside
then the state
victimized me by
not doing them to them what they should
have done to them
you know everybody you pay for
everything in life eventually
if not in this life you'll pay for it in
the next
but
forgiveness is the hardest emotion i
have to deal with
because i don't want to take that hate
and that anger with me when i go
when i go to meet my maker
i just call god i don't want to have
hate or anger in my heart
i don't want to be that type of person
now i wish them no harm
i hope their kids and their families
are healthy and happy
but i hope they never forget that they
did it off my blood sweat and tears
forgiveness is something you do for
yourself not for someone else
yeah i think forgiving myself is the
hardest thing
because i felt like i should have told
people but forgiving others is something
you do for yourself i can forgive others
it is real it's weird it's the same
thing whether you're forgiving others or
yourself i can't forgive myself because
i felt like i should have spoke out more
i should have
pulled back my mom had cancer my brother
i'm the youngest of five
and they all just abandoned her
i had to stay there and deal with it all
like i you know they didn't they
with my mom was a drunk she was a bad
drunk
and she i thought she was a violent
drunk
so they didn't have to deal with any of
it they all took off and left
yeah i sit there and i dealt with it
when the five year you know i have to
hold a mirror under my mom's nose
to see if she's alive because i'm afraid
that the state's gonna come and take me
away again at five years old
please there's no way to live poor
and then they throw you into some type
of youth home and it's even worse
because you
get this sense of you feel abandoned
and
they don't show you how to deal with
that throughout the rest of your life
i've never felt loved before in my life
not as a kid
not as an adult
what about your husband
i believe he loved me he had love for me
but he wasn't in love with me
i was i think he
what i wanted to uh
i was the party girl
he was nerdy
and
he wanted that life
i provided it for him
i fell in love with him but
i felt like god punished me for that
like just when i reached
what i thought was love
god took it away from me
so
with tony
i'm afraid god's gonna take it away
so i'm a [ __ ]
because it's easier
because i couldn't take it if god took
him away do you feel like life is unfair
no
not for me
i made my choices
everything i did
i did it i made the choice i am where i
am because i made these choices
not anybody else nobody put a gun to my
head and told me to shoot up nobody put
a gun in my hand tell somebody goes like
a dick no we just hit any of that
i made the conscious choice to do it
myself
and there was people who tried to pull
me out the lifestyle
there i met some great people along the
way my friend shonda i would walk from
here to san antonio if she needed me
she her and her family showed me
unconditional love for the first time in
my life
she was there for me when nobody else
was
through my suicide attempts through
the countless
ods and stuff like that
because
if i was gonna do it i was gonna do it
hard so i didn't know how to do a little
bit of dope i would
slam it all in
why why do you think such a high
percentage of
transgender women are sex workers
because who's going to hire us
honestly
we wouldn't transsexuals we walk out in
the world especially i hate to say this
because it's gonna sound ugly but the
girls that are passable have it harder
than the girls that are not passable
because when the girls the girls that
are not possible somebody sees them they
say oh they know what they are
so they're going to cuss maybe
the girls that are passable
they have it harder because guys don't
know what we are so when they see us
coming down the street and they feel
like we fooled them
they want to hurt us they want to hit us
they want to beat us shoot us rape us
they want to do something to extinguish
our light
because
they feel like we fooled them
but we didn't fool them we're just
living our lives
i feel like the gay lesbian community
they forget about the transsexuals
that
glbtq whatever
they leave the transsexuals out
they don't understand our struggle
because
they we're not gay
transsexuals aren't gay we feel like
we're women we know we're women
so
they're kind of like
trans rights are really important
they're really really important i've
lost a lot of friends i've had friends
die when they didn't have to die i had a
friend who was put in an incinerator
when she didn't have to be
if you know people are more educated in
school and stuff like that
but then there's a lot of transsexuals
that need to stop doing what they do too
stop trying to fool a guy stop trying to
get a straight boy you know it doesn't
matter
find somebody that loves you find
somebody that you love doesn't matter
what they look like or who they are or
what's between their legs
just
find out who they are
look past
beauty is only skin deep and you're
never gonna look beautiful forever
so what are you afraid of what are you
worried about
honestly
everything that could possibly have
happened to me has happened to me
already
i'm not afraid
i'm not afraid to meet my maker
i don't want to
but i'm not afraid
i have no fears
i figure
this life is bad the next one will be
better
hopefully
and if not maybe i'll come back as a
butterfly or something
if you had your life to live all over
again what would you have done
differently
nothing
nothing i like who i am now
i have a lot of love in my heart
for everybody
for people i don't even know i have love
for them
because i know what pain feels like
and nobody should have to feel that
and besides along my journey
to get here
i met some really amazing people
i've met some really sad people
but i've met some really amazing people
along the way too
and i wouldn't want to change that for
anything
what's been your lowest point
losing my mom and my husband
i am trying to kill myself twice
didn't happen um
that was my lowest point that's when i
thought it was so dark
and then my sister-in-law barbie
i was at a good well with a friend of
mine and i saw her
and her and her kids saved my life
i needed a family so bad
they invited me into their family to be
their family
they saved my life
demon shonda
a bigger part of your current situation
is your drug addiction
it's not that big my drug i mean i do
drugs but what do you what do you use
mostly
um no i like fentanyl
but i was doing heroin before fentanyl i
used fitting all to get off of heroin
and then got stuck doing fentanyl
so it was like a double-edged sword for
me i was tired i was doing heroin for 12
years
from the day my husband died to
the day i found fentanyl
and
for some strange reason my body just
like adapted to it i could smoke mass
amounts of it and nothing happens to me
but i've seen friends drop dead off just
like
one hit
and um
i used heroin to numb the pain but
fentanyl doesn't numb the pain
if anything it amplifies it
i used to think it was hereditary
my mom was addicted to xenx
my dad used to do speed
so and they were both alcoholics
and i drink i'm an alcoholic
i do drugs
but i went from having like
about a 1500 habit
to like having a 40 habit
which is pretty good for me
baby steps
do you have people in your life do you
trust no
that's sad
yeah
but
the people that are in my life right now
they're um
they were taught i come from a different
world than they do
they've never they
how do i say it without something ugly
they've never had anything
so when they see something they want
they're they don't hell in high water's
gonna keep it from me
and no matter who they hurt in between i
can't be that way i'm not like that
i care about people's feelings and
i don't like hurting people because
i know what it feels like
you don't want inflicted on anybody else
ever again
where do you stay now
different places we're in a we're
staying in a tent now
we tried out when that project room key
came through me we signed up for it
never heard back from the people um
what's that lassa delayed from lassa she
would come by every other weekend and
tell us oh i got a place for you
i'll be here next week and then she
would never show up
i think she's
came by like maybe four times in the
last year
so
they never helped us get into any of
those projects project room key or
anything like that but i think it's
because we're trying to stay together
that they're just like
and a lot of places don't want to like
those those
things don't want to take transsexuals
they don't want us to go there because
we pose
security risks or
problems with the other guests
and i understand that but
don't exclude us either because there's
a lot of transsexuals living on the
streets right now
do you believe in karma yeah
very much so how does karma play out in
your life
well i must have been really evil in my
last life like maybe hitler or stalin or
something because
i've suffered for
10 lifetimes in this one
so my next one hopefully i'll be
something better
i'll get a better life
maybe not try to help so many people
when i can't barely help myself
scarlett what would you say is the most
important lesson you've learned in your
life
love
it's the most important lesson
to love myself to love other people
to show kindness compassion
to care
not just about myself but about
people i don't even know
because if this was ever going to change
we got to do it one person at a time
so i'm going to be kind and love
everybody i can
all right scarlett thank you so much for
sharing you're welcome
i wish you the best of our content
you